Ich denke, das ist eine sehr schlechte Idee, denn
wenn Sie die Cops sind, die die
ganze Zeit mit Waffen herumlaufen und versehentlich auf
Leute schießen, also ich meine, ein Lehrer, der
eine Waffe hat, könnte an einen bestimmten Punkt
mit einem Schüler gelangen, oder zwei Schüler könnten
in eine Rauferei geraten  und der Lehrer
könnte eine Waffe ziehen, die Sie kennen, um es zu stoppen, und
sie könnten uns versehentlich erschießen, wenn Sie es tun. Ich
denke, das ist eine verrückte Idee
, die verrückt ist. Dieses Problem mit Waffengewalt
ist eine große Sache, weil wir Kinder an
jeder Ecke haben, die in der Lage sind zu bekommen  Waffen
aus jeder Ecke und es ist einfach schwer für einen
normalen Teenager nach New York, weil
wir so viele Waffen und
Messer und andere Ausrüstung zugänglich haben. Vor zwei Tagen hatte
meine Schwester mir erzählt, dass ein
neunjähriges oder ein achtjähriges Mädchen gerne erschossen wurde
nicht weit von hier, also ist
sie wie verletzt, niemand weiß, dass es ihr
gut geht oder so.
Ein Programm namens Hip Hop rettet Leben,
wenn wir Kinder über die wahre Geschichte
des Hip Hop aufklären und wie Kinder Selbstverantwortung
für ihre Kommunikation übernehmen  nities und
stoppen Sie die Gewalt in ihren Gemeinden
und haben diesen Bandenfriedensvertrag geschaffen und
wir schreien jetzt, wir segnen
Sie, Emily, entkommen Sie, Sie wissen, ich habe viel
Selbstwertgefühl, Selbstliebe und
Selbstachtung durch große Künstler gefunden
und mich so ausdrücken können, wie wir es wollen
das den Kindern zu geben, um ihnen zu helfen,
Songs zu schreiben und die ganze
[Musik] zu produzieren